[Música]
i
en el corazón de los alpes el parque del
mercante
es reconocido por ser uno de los pocos
lugares vírgenes de francia aquí los
animales salvajes son protegidos
entonces para quienes trabajan en este
parque hacer coexistir esta naturaleza
bruta con las actividades humanas es un
desafío cotidiano
aditya ghosh
zanahorias estas son las nuevas verduras
que crecen en la montaña es un poco la
calamidad la gente viene con bolsas de
zanahorias manzanas para alimentar a las
marmotas y es una catástrofe no hay que
hacerlo pero es más fuerte que ellos
corren el riesgo de recibir una monada
no alimentar a los animales pero también
saber ser discreto
no hay que acercarse mucho para no
molestar las
y
las marmotas tienen varias madrigueras
la principal con una o dos entradas
luego tienen madrigueras de vida que les
permiten protegerse cuando las molestan
pero no son madrigueras profundas son
sólo pequeños corredores para protegerse
se ha instalado un hilo con el fin de
preservar la quietud del animal
los turistas deben permanecer a
distancia
a 80 kilómetros de aquí cerca a la
frontera italiana ya nadie se vasco
naturalista jubilado nos conduce al
monte
para descubrir un lugar arqueológico
clasificado como un monumento histórico
por la unesco
37 mil grabados rupestres han sido
identificados en el sector
aquí hay un círculo en el que está
encerrado y separado por una barrera muy
simbólica
un toro con sus cuernos con forma de
vida
y aquí hay un personaje con los brazos
hacia arriba como jurando abajo las
piernas
grabados realizados 2200 años antes de
nuestra era con una técnica nueva para
la época de
dibujos realizados con punteado es decir
que el hombre de la prehistoria usaba
una herramienta para realizar pequeños
huecos llamados cúpulas y golpeando con
una rotación se realiza el dibujo la
dicta mente punto por punto
estos grabados que representan con
frecuencia a toros o carreteras
constituyen el testimonio más antiguo en
los alpes de la presencia de pastores y
agricultores
actualmente la tradición pastoral se
perpetúa en el parque del mes canto
se desplaza a los altos pastos para ver
a sus animales
es criatura de megan de caballos de
montaña
y esto que es la decana
fue la primera la primera en nacer hace
30 años y sigue aquí es blanca y es la
jefa
lo primero que hace uy su esposo es
verificar que sus 14 yeguas están aquí
cuentos y siempre hay que contar que
hace falta una es que hay un problema o
se quedó en algún rincón busca
inmediatamente es lo primero que hago
y temen sobre todo a los ataques de los
lobos
los lobos son nuestra preocupación
durante los últimos 20 años hemos
perdido 11
vivo con ese temor no por la muerte sino
por el sufrimiento de mis caballos y
ello es insoportable para mí porque los
lobos no están disculpados para matar
animales grandes entonces son
oportunistas no gastan mucha energía
para matar a un animal cuando no lo
logran empiezan a comerse lo vivo
los lobos llegaron a italia a principios
de los años 90
hoy en día son unos 40 en el mercante
distribuidos en ocho manadas atacan con
frecuencia a los rebaños
en general a los corderos
para proteger sus rebaños los creadores
necesitan perros pastores adiestrados
para enfrentar al lugar
son perros de protección tuve uno que
fue asesinado este año por lo de
los perros es aproximadamente son como
los soldados
el lobo llega del bosque no puedo hacer
nada
los perros limitan un poco las pérdidas
pero es todo
un perro asesinado este año pero también
en 42 ovejas nos encontramos en una zona
de riesgo neon creo que parque
estamos en el corazón del parque
desafortunadamente para mí solo puedo
soportar los ataques de los nuevos
porque aquí no podría ahuyentar los
wizards
o no
[Música]
en el mes canto el lobo es un símbolo el
de una naturaleza que se rebela y se
impone al hombre uno de los pocos
espacios en francia donde se protege
realmente la vida salvaje